Speaker 1: Let's go to Colin from Ukraine.
Are you in Ukraine, Kellan?
Speaker 6: Hi, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
I live in Kiev and I've lived there for the
last 11 years, but I actually came back to
the U.S. for business on February 1st.
Oh, OK.
But my wife, my cat and all of her family
are still in Ukraine, and she actually just
got out of Kiev with an armed guard last week
and went to the West.
Speaker 1: Wow.
And do you like so OK?
Talk me through the logistics of that.
Do you hire an armed guard to help your wife
get to the west of the country?
Speaker 6: So her dad is fairly well connected.
He is a director of a regional hospital in
western Ukraine.
So he has a lot of people who owe him favors.
I see.
And so he was able to talk to one of his connections
who happened to be in Kiev at the time of
the invasion, and he had special military
permission to be out after curfew.
And he was also allowed to carry a concealed
weapon.
So he came to our apartment and took our car
with my wife and cat and some of her belongings.
Speaker 1: So the cat went with your wife.
That's good to hear, at least.
Yeah.
Now let me ask you this.
Have you have you have been not you, but have
you together as a unit?
Are you planning to go back to Kiev when?
Speaker 6: As soon as the proper number of
Russians have been sent home in body bags.
Wow.
Speaker 1: So in other words, you're not abandoning
Kiev, you're just waiting for the violence
to end.
Speaker 6: Yeah, and I left there on February
1st for business purposes to come back to
the U.S.. Yeah.
And was was planning on returning.
But it's not.
It's not possible.
I mean, it's very hard to even get back into
Kiev right now if you want to, unless you
have some kind of military protection.
And I'm not a trained soldier, I and the Ukrainian
government has asked weekend warriors to stay
away.
And that's exactly what I would be.
So I'm respecting that that call from the
government.
Speaker 1: And are you American married to
a Ukrainian woman or are you Ukrainian?
Speaker 6: I'm American.
Married to Ukrainian.
I have residency in the country.
OK, yeah.
We have a couple of apartments in Kiev.
A rocket that was fired into the city and
landed near our bank, which is about two blocks
away from where our home and destroyed quite
a bit of it, knocked out all the windows and
the surrounding area.
So.
Speaker 1: So can you talk a little bit about,
you know, in the news we see Russia has has
bombed random apartment buildings and then
later you'll hear the attempt at a rationalization
by saying, Well, we believe dissidents and
combatants were planning violent activities
in those apartment buildings.
Do you know anything about that?
Is it literally just like all of a sudden,
just a missile hits an apartment building?
Speaker 6: So the Territorial Defense Forces
are set up basically in every district in
the city.
So there are people who have weapons on the
ground in quite a few places in the city.
But like I just saw the destruction around
Lukyanov Lukyanov metro station, which is
about 10 minutes away from our apartment.
Yeah.
And I didn't see any military on the ground
near that metro station, but it wouldn't surprise
me if there were territorial defense forces
in and around that area because it is a major
metro station.
It's fairly deep.
Speaker 1: So in a literal sense, when Russia
says, well, those apartment buildings in or
right outside of them had forces.
So Ukrainian forces
Speaker 6: every room of every building in
Ukraine right now as people that are willing
to kill Russians in it.
Speaker 1: Right, right, right, right.
So it just sort of.
Yeah.
Wow, wow.
All right.
And then so and for the time being, you're
just hanging tight in the US.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I'm actually I'm in Austin
with my younger brother.
And, you know, still trying to go about business
life is as much as I can.
I've been doing quite a few interviews with
with local media back in my home state of
Nebraska, just trying to get the word out.
And this was actually part of my what.
What I wanted to ask you about is I have firsthand
experience of living in that country for 11
years, getting to know thousands of Ukrainians
and never seeing any kind of neo-Nazi movements
or any other than the very far right which,
like the Azov Battalion, does have a very
right wing leanings.
And there are some people, but not any more
so than than there are in any other country
in the world.
I mean, their Jewish president got, I think
it was 71 or 73 percent of the vote.
So I've talked to a lot of people in the U.S.
who are just repeating ad nauseum the same
Russian propaganda that I got to hear aplenty
from Russian media.
Speaker 1: And are the people repeating that
stuff in the U.S. and your experience?
Do they tend to be more on the right or the
left in the U.S.?
Speaker 6: Tinfoil hat right wingers?
Oh, OK, OK, OK.
Well, my question is if I can't convince them,
having lived in the country for 11 years,
participated in the Maidan revolution on the
ground.
And I actually have firsthand knowledge of
this kind of stuff.
What hope is there for any kind of intelligent
conversation about when we should put boots
on the ground, when we should go in there,
how much protection we should provide them,
why we should care about them if I can't convince
them of that.
What hope is there of anyone else to convince
them?
Speaker 1: No.
Regardless of your views as to what the answers
to those questions should be with the people
you're describing, you're not going to be
able to have a real, sensible conversation
about those issues, sadly, but you're just
not.
All right
Speaker 6: now.
Well, thanks for taking my call and for listening.
Speaker 1: All right, well, listen, let's
hope everybody in the family and everybody
in Ukraine stays safe, OK?
All right.
There is Kellen, who lives in Ukraine.